you know you had a tough time growing
Elsa your parents didn't understand your
powers and they made you stay totally
isolated limit her contact with people
keep her powers hidden every it's
seriously depressing but you proved that
you are an awesome sister and Queen and
frozen and now you'll be using your cool
ice powers all over again in frozen 2 we
know times are hard but we hope you can
let it go you deserve a happily ever
after just like every other Disney
Princess what will happen to Elsa after
frozen to keep watching to find out the
hottest we mean coolest theories we are
so pumped that Disney is giving us the
sequel to frozen we just can't wait to
see more of Elsa's amazing powers
according to the trailer Elsa has to
dive deep into her past to discover the
truth we don't know what truth pabbie is
referring to but it sounds super serious
pabbie also tells Anna that he hopes
Elsa's powers are enough to save them
all Elsa is awesome we have no doubt
that she will save everybody but once
she's done saving arendelle and the rest
of the world what will happen
I also had a seriously messed-up
childhood she almost ended on his life
with her powers that is traumatizing
then her parents kept her totally
isolated because they were scared of her
magic plus she lost her parents in a
shipwreck she also put arendelle on a
huge Blizzard and Hans nearly stole her
Kingdom we think after her adventure in
frozen - it's time for Elsa to get a
happily ever after but what will that
look like the Internet is buzzing with
theories about else's future we picked
the three most likely scenarios for this
video the first one has everything to do
with a certain DreamWorks character Jack
Frost one of the most popular ships and
the animated fandoms is Elsa and Jack
Frost we know we know one is Disney and
the other isn't but since they're all
fictional characters to begin with it's
sort of checks out and these two do seem
like the perfect pair I also spent most
of her life being totally misunderstood
not even the trolls really understood
her powers and as far as she knows she
is the only person who has ice and snow
abilities imagine how happy she would be
if she found out there was someone just
like her both Jack Frost and Elsa spent
most of their lives as loners and they
were both willing to do anything for
their sisters they also have very
similar magical abilities we can see it
now Elsa would build a magical snowy
wedding venue Anna would be her maid of
honor Olaf would definitely be the ring
bearer Jack can still fulfill his
guardian duties while Elsa stays busy
ruling arendelle with the two of them
arendelle would continue to have a
thriving ice block economy Elsa can
probably even figure out a way to ship
ice to other places Jack and Elsa would
turn arendelle into an even richer
trading port and with both of them in
control no one would dare try to take
over ever again we're looking at you
Hans just look how cute they would be
together
we love this fan art from deviant
artists chou-heung zu and Ikey han this
is a really popular pairing do you ship
Elsa and Jack Frost
alsa gets a girlfriend as soon as people
realize that Elsa had no love interest
in frozen the internet began posting
about the possibilities of her having a
girlfriend
Disney has very subtly been introducing
LGBTQ characters but they have all been
in the background both finding Dory and
Toy Story 4 featured same gender couples
and in the remake of Beauty and the
Beast it's scented that Lefou love for
Gaston maybe a little more romantic than
you thought but plenty of people think
it's time for a same-gender couple to be
included in a major storyline and Elsa
is the perfect candidate there is even a
Twitter hashtag called give Elsa a
girlfriend Elsa has already learned how
to be herself when it comes to her magic
it would be great if she can totally
accept her full identity but the
director for frozen 2 has neither
confirmed or denied the rumors that Elsa
gets a girlfriend some people think that
the dark-haired girl in the frozen
trailer is going to be else's love
interest however Elsa identifies we just
want her to be happy it seems only
fitting that I offer you your first
dance as Queen single and happy of
course
Elsa doesn't have to have a love
interest Elsa is already super busy
being the queen of arendelle arendelle
is a major Kingdom lots of people want
to trade with them that's why everyone
was so pumped when Elsa opened arendelle
up to the rest of the world being a
queen of a major Kingdom is hard work
Elsa may not be interested in doing
anything but ruling and she definitely
doesn't need anyone to help her rule
she's an amazing Queen as she is we can
see Elsa making arendelle the most
powerful country in the fictional disney
world and it's not like she would be
totally alone she'll have Anna and
Kristoff and we just know those two will
have adorable little kids Elsa will be
an amazing aunt she can play with her
nieces and nephews the way she did with
Anna when they were small she also got
her buddy Olaf what do you think will
happen to Elsa after frozen - will she
get married or live that single life
tell us your theories in the comment
section thanks for watching the things
for more videos about your favorite
Disney movies hit that subscribe button
and don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up we'll see you next time
[Music]